[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL RASHIDI: Hello, my
name's Paul Rashidi.
Thanks for joining us
again for another
third party hang out.
Today, we have ADvendio, who is
a key partner with the DFP
API for many publishers
who utilize the
Salesforce.com platform.
They simplify order management,
as well as many
other processes for
publishers.
And I apologize, I didn't
introduce the other DFP API
member on the conference
today.
Vincent, would you like
to introduce yourself?
VINCENT TSAO: Sure.
My name is Vincent Tsao.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the DFP API team.
I work primarily on the
PHP client library.
PAUL RASHIDI: Thanks
Vincent, and sorry.
So with that, I'll go ahead and
introduce Nadja Streiss,
sales manager for ADvendio.
And she'll let us know what
ADvendio does for their
publishers.
NADJA STREISS: Hi.
Well, so hi.
Yeah, thank you Paul.
My name is Nadja.
I'm one of the sales reps
here for ADvendio.
And let me introduce my team.
To my left is Freddy, the
project developer.
And--
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Hi.
NADJA STREISS: --on the
other screen is
Reno, our project manager.
Say hi.
Yeah, that's it.
I would be the one who's going
to introduce you to the
company, ADvendio itself.
And we can get started, I think,
if you're ready, Paul?
PAUL RASHIDI: Yeah,
sounds great.
NADJA STREISS: So let me just
switch to our presentation.
So, just a second.
Yes, we are correct.
So ADvendio.com, as a complete
sales and order management
app, was an additional invoice
management model especially
designed for online
publishers.
Powered by Salesforce.com, you
receive all benefits of the
innovative cloud platform.
ADvendio's main goal is to
simplify your complex online
advertising business by
providing one system where all
relevant information
is stored.
Ans advertisers, inventory
campaigns, and proposals,
orders, reports, and invoices
can be managed within this
application.
As ADvendio.com seamlessly
integrates with DFP,
publishers can process almost
everything in that venue.
This solution is particularly
designed for digital
publishers who want to make the
most of the premium sales.
So just a brief overview
also of what's planned.
And this is our flier.
As you can see, ADvendio.com
includes all tools you need to
manage your ad sales
efficiently.
Not only does it contain an
inventory database that you
can organize, mass update, and
easily search with [INAUDIBLE]
lookups, but also a powerful
CRM, which helps your team to
see all customer information and
interaction at a glance.
Thanks to the integration with
DFP, you can easily create and
configure campaigns, and
immediately request
availabilities, and submit the
order on DFP from within
ADvendio.com, without even
having to enter everything all
over again.
Furthermore, the analytics tool
gives you the opportunity
to create and customize any
report you might need to
evaluate customer inventory
or sales rep performance.
I will tell you more about the
billing functionality on a
separate slide later on.
We just move forward.
Yes, benefits.
Thanks to the embedded network
integration, ADvendio's main
benefit is that you can manage
your business in one system.
ADvendio is built and operated
on Salesforce.com's innovative
cloud infrastructure.
You can access your business
data anywhere, anytime, on any
device, and benefit from low
initial costs, and continuing
free updates.
You don't have to worry about
IT maintenance or about your
company's growth, ADvendio's
multi-tenant solution fits
company size.
With the chatter of the
integrated communication tool
from Salesforce, you can also
easily just collaborate with
your coworkers.
On this slide, as I have already
mentioned, ADvendio
includes a complete CRM, an
[INAUDIBLE] with its tasks,
and activity tracking, a great
management cockpit with 360
degrees customer visibility.
You can not only create
proposals for your online
mandatory, but for
print, as well.
Thanks to the handy inventory
search and media integration,
you can quickly create and
optimize your campaigns.
Now the promised billing
and accounting slide.
The new billing and accounting
tool allows you to create
automated invoices that you
are running, or completed
media campaigns, within
just a few clicks.
With the help of comprehensive
billing rounds, you can even
generate, for example, all
months invoices, and merge
them into one file for
immediate print shop.
If an invoice has to be altered,
you can cancel
invoice position, and
automatically create credit
notes for the changed
position.
Furthermore, the accounting
tool offers you the
possibility of creating reports
of the actual account
inventory performance
after invoicing.
Via the admin's web service
API, it's possible to
integrate with the
ERP systems.
Now the embedded DFP
integration.
Thanks to the of connection to
the DFP, data can be exchanged
automatically between
the two systems.
Basically, the integration
allows sales ad ops and
campaign management to use DFP
functions, such as forecast,
booking, and delivery data
within ADvendio, so that
information just has
to be entered once.
During the campaign planning
process, sales rep can enter
targeting information
linked with DFP.
So if they want to request
availabilities for the
configured campaigns, targeting
criteria is
considered during the
forecast, as well.
They can see immediately if and
how the entered amounts
have to be altered.
Once the proposal is confirmed,
they can upload the
creative and push the media
campaign with all relevant
information to DFP
with one click.
As soon as a campaign is
running, you get the actual
delivered impressions and
clicks-back the media
campaign, where they
can be used for be
reporting or billing.
With ADvendio and the
integration to DFP, CRM, order
management, billing, and order
operations don't have to be
coordinated separately
anymore.
So this was--
just change.
This was a brief company
overview on ADvendio, and the
packages, order management,
and the
invoicing management part.
And I'll just go and give over
to Reno, who's going to
introduce you to the
live system.
And show you around how the
integration works exactly.
RENO MILEWSKI: Hi, everybody.
OK, now everybody can see me?
Hi, everybody.
Thank you, Nadja.
I'm Reno, and as a product
manager of ADvendio, I'm
responsible for evaluating,
planning, and implementing new
features, so making our solution
even more efficient.
Thanks to the flexible cloud
architecture, almost every
enhancement can be realized,
and all these updates are
usually for free.
So I'm going to give you a brief
overview of the basic
features of ADvendio.com.
We'll take a quick tour through
accounts, contacts,
customer care, create
a media campaign
using the media search.
Of course, see how the
connection to DFP works, and
creating a proposal, and
finally, an invoice.
So let's take a look
at our live system.
I just need to show
my desktop here.
All right.
So now you should
see my screen.
This home screen is exactly what
every user can see if he
accesses to ADvendio.
He has immediately his planned
events and tasks at a glance,
as you can see it here.
So every user can schedule his
own tasks, his own meetings,
and so can define the
collaboration.
He also can assign tasks
to other users, and
create his own tasks.
You can see dashboard here,
where he can make reports a
little bit more visible.
But let us go through
the system.
In ADvendio, you have everything
in one system.
So you have your accounts and
contact information, as you
can see here, which are your
advertisers and your agencies.
You have also the whole
inventory management, with the
aspects and size placement
ad types.
The report engine and the
dashboard engine.
And what your ads have,
the media campaigns.
So if you go to the Accounts
tab, you just see here the
client account.
In the top page, you see
the account's details.
So all needed business
information, like an annual
revenue, or the phone number.
In the bottom, you see
all related lists.
So all records which are
connected to this account,
like the contact persons, and
the media campaigns, which you
have for this account.
So let's go through to see
one media campaign.
If you want to create a new
media campaign, just click on
your Media Campaigns tab,
and click on New.
So I've already created
one media campaign.
a campaign.
And in the top again, you see
all basic information to this
media campaign, like the media
campaign name, the advertising
agency relationship.
You can also define stage with
the media probability, and the
close date.
In another section, you see all
calculations and discounts.
You can grant quantity,
customer, and agency discounts
on a media campaign level.
And what your ads can
do is see, on a
later stage, all amounts.
And campaigns start and ended
were calculated in the
background by the system,
depending on the given
information in the related
list campaign items.
So here comes the media campaign
management with the
inventory management together.
So if you just click on Add
Items, you come to the
products search--
the media search.
Here you can filter the results
of all the inventory
you have stored in the system.
So for example, you can
define a site, the
placement, the ad type.
You can search for the
billing category.
And in this case, just let us
search for Friday News.
It's just a demo site here.
And it's taking some seconds.
And the ad type wide skyscraper,
for example.
And we will see that there's
just one product in the system
with these criterias.
The Friday news home
page skyscraper.
If you mark this and get add
it to the basket, you will
come to the next screen
to the basket.
You now can set up a new search,
if you want to, and
add another more products
to your basket.
What you now can do is start
your media configuration.
So you want to have some
basic information to
this campaign item.
Just pick on Start Media
Configuration, and you come to
this screen.
So the Friday News home page
white skyscraper, the name of
this ad spec.
What you now can do is select
the from and until date.
So we need to define
the period.
Let's make it in March.
Define your pricing.
On different tabs you have
different information.
So let's take 100,000
impressions.
You also can change the sales
price if you want to.
You have your frequency capping
information, which are
also submitted to
your ad server.
Your time targeting,
browser targeting--
I'll just skip those tasks
at the moment.
Your geo-information which you
can pull out from DFP with
just one click, and everything
is stored in your system.
And this geo-targeting tree will
pop up automatically if
you click this button
here on Edit.
For example, you can now define
your geo-targeting
information let's make it in
Arizona, in Arizona City, and
click save.
And all this information is
stored here in these boxes,
and were also pushed to
your DFP network.
You can define your key value
information and content
information, but skip
it for the moment.
Just click on Save, and you
come to the next screen.
Here, come back to the
media campaign.
So you now have one campaign
item in this
media company here.
What you now can do is to
check availability.
So just mark it and check
availability.
Since this system is connected
to our test environment for
DFP, we have no availables in
the system because we have no
live campaigns running
in the system.
So I would like to skip the
check availability for the
moment, and show you the submit
to ad server directly.
It's nearly the same
procedure.
But first of all, we need to
sign the proposal or send it
out to the agency.
So we need to generate
the PDF.
With just two clicks, you
will have your PDF.
Sent it directly to the
agency, and the
agency signs it.
And you're able to push the
campaign to the ad server.
Or, make some changes,
and push it after
you make your changes.
OK, so let's put it to the ad
server with just one click.
Oh--
that was a button arrow.
I'm not quite sure what it is.
But if you now see it in here,
we have a live campaign.
In this live campaign,
you will see--
just let me skip it
to another tab.
And in this live campaign, you
can see, if you have pushed it
to your ad server, then the ad
server auto ID and ad ID were
filled out automatically.
You have also delivery status
updates with the delivered
clicks and impressions with
the last delivery update--
when was the last
delivery update.
So this is the German
time here.
Let's take the deliveries
for this campaign here.
Just click on our--
just mark this item, and get
delivered clicks and
impressions here.
So we come to the new
screen, and--
illegal session.
PAUL RASHIDI: I think those
pop-outs timed you out.
RENO MILEWSKI: I'm
not quite sure.
Maybe Freddy can [INAUDIBLE]
can tell you something
more about it.
I think I need to refresh
it, and then it will
work, because I have--
just one moment.
OK, so now we have
a fresh session.
And let's get delivered
clicks.
Now it takes some seconds for
the connection to a DFP, and
get out the new delivered clicks
and impressions and for
this ad ID.
And you can now see it in your
campaign item that the last
delivery status update will be
popped up automatically here.
So here's our time,
and it works.
So, the next thing I want to
show you is the billing.
So if you now have some
campaigns running on the
system, and everything's fine,
and the deliveries are coming
back to your system, you just
need to start the billing run.
So just click on your
billing information.
You have some campaigns in the
billing run, which are, for
example, for January.
We want to start the billing
run for February--
January, sorry.
And you are able to show all
records which are relevant for
this billing run.
So I just want to show you
this pre-invoices.
I hope there are some.
Yeah so now we have three
campaigns, which
are ready for invoice.
You see that there are also
some records in there.
And I can invoice with these
records with just one click.
There will be created a new
billing run record with the
invoice sys, and the
invoice numbers.
So these invoice numbers are
generated by the system
automatically.
And you can see all needed
information in these records
here, directly pulled out of
the campaign items and the
media campaigns, which they
are connected to.
And you can see the invoice as
a PDF here with this title.
And we can just click of View,
and you see this invoice
number here.
And you have your invoice,
and you can send
it out to your agency.
So, yes, that's on my side.
I hope this quick overview
helped you get a better
understanding of how
ADvendio works.
So now I can see me.
I'll hand over to Frederik, and
he will show you a little
bit more about the API.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Yes.
Hi everyone.
I'm Frederik.
I'm a software developer at
ADvendio, and responsible for
the ad server integration
of the DFP ad server.
I'm going to show you
some more detailed--
some more technical information
about how we
integrate with the DFP server.
Wait a moment.
So basically, we have three
parts of our ADvendio server
integration.
We have the ADvendio app,
which is [INAUDIBLE] in
Salesforce, as you have seen
in Reno's presentation.
We have on the other, of
course, the DFP server.
And between these two, we have
our middleware, or our ad
server interface.
So you have already seen what
information may be passed from
ADvendio to the web server,
and what functionality is
available for integrating
with the ad server.
First of all, we have some
buttons, as you have seen in
Reno's presentation.
We have to check availability
check.
RENO MILEWSKI: Freddy, I think
you have a presentation.
Could you share your
screen with us?
FREDERIK LADEWIG:
Oh, I'm sorry.
Wait a moment.
OK, I hope you see my
screen right now.
PAUL RASHIDI: Yes.
RENO MILEWSKI: Thanks
a lot, Freddy.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: OK, then
again, you see the three parts
of the ADvendio solution.
We have the ADvendio app on the
left side, the DFP server
on the right side, and our
middleware in the center.
So what do we do when--
what a customer has to do when
you install ADvendio?
We have first to set up an
installation [INAUDIBLE]
where we transfer all or a lot
of data from the ad server to
use it in our ADvendio app.
For this, we use, of course, the
company service, or custom
targeting server or T-values.
The inventory service to import
accurate placements and
labels and countries and
regions and cities.
We import by using
the publisher
query language service.
So that's our first set-up.
PAUL RASHIDI: I'm
sorry, Freddy.
We're having a little
problem seeing your
slide on the broadcast.
Could you unshared
and reshare?
FREDERIK LADEWIG:
Wait a minute.
OK, better now?
PAUL RASHIDI: It's not.
But go and speak to it.
We'll try and correct
it later.
We can see the slide,
it's just blurry.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: OK, maybe
you see the slide now.
But OK, I hope it's--
OK.
OK, let me just show you how
this works together.
And we have, as you've seen,
buttons in ADvendio.
And I'm going to show you an
example of the forecast of how
this works in detail.
So what happens first-- the user
clicks on this button.
And the button calls, via HTTPS,
our Java [INAUDIBLE],
which is hosted of course
in the cloud.
The Java [INAUDIBLE]
connect back to Salesforce,
loads all data we neat, all
media campaign data, and all
line item and account data
that we need.
And when all data is loaded, we
transfer a media campaign
to a DFP order.
And of course, all campaign
items to DFP line items.
So when we have down this, we
use of course the forecast
service, and call to the
forecast operation.
This message-- this do
forecast message--
gives us back a forecast
object where we get all
available impressions, and
some more information.
We save this information back
to Salesforce through our
ADvendio app, and send
an email to the user.
And the submit to ad server
works almost the same.
And almost every operation
works in the
same way like this.
Now let's come to the new API,
and how it is compared to
other APIs from other ad
servers, and especially
compared to the old DFP API.
And what do we like on
the new DFP API.
First of all, it's very good
structured, and you can really
intuitively use this API.
Yes, every function and
object [INAUDIBLE]
is understandable.
And you see it and know
what it's for.
So it's, of course,
state-of-the-art technology
that the API uses.
We have a good data model--
[INAUDIBLE]
data model--
yeah, it just makes sense.
We have no situation where
you're saying, oops, where do
we get the information now?
I can't find it.
Everything makes sense,
and it's just clear.
And then we have the complete
API documentation.
We have [INAUDIBLE] for every
service, for every function,
every object that we use.
We have documented, and
it's a great help.
We have test networks--
that's another part.
You don't need to have
a premium account.
You don't really need
to contact Google.
You just, as a developer, you
can just create your own test
network and text whatever
you like.
Especially at the beginning,
these test networks are a
great help.
The new DFP API is on some sites
very much more faster
than the old API.
Especially if you want to do a
targeting, you have to do less
calls to the ad server, and it
makes everything faster.
And of course, we have a
community, we have a forum
where we can ask and
find answers and
problems of other users.
OK, yes, that was my part.
And I think you might have
some questions now.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
Thanks, Freddy.
Vincent, did you--
I know you had a
few questions.
Do you want to ask him first?
NADJA STREISS: I think
he's on mute.
PAUL RASHIDI: Yeah,
I think he is.
So, while he works through
that, I'll just ask--
it seemed like, from a reporting
perspective, you can
report on campaigns before and
after the upgrade, which I
know is very important for the
pubs that are upgrading.
Could you talk a little bit
more about how your
reporting does that?
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Oh, yes.
That's quite easy.
Since we just replaced the IDs
of the old campaigns and the
old orders by the new ones, we
just have the nudge columns in
the report where we get the
delivery data before the
update, before the change.
And together with the new,
more recent data.
And so, yeah, it's quite easy.
We only have to use these nudge
columns, and get all
report data we need.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great, great.
So it's just one continuous
report.
You deal with the data.
The data changes on
your side, right?
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Right.
PAUL RASHIDI: Perfect.
The only other thing I wanted
to mention is during Reno's
presentation, he went through
the geo-targeting selection,
and then also showed us the
key value selection.
So one of the things that I
think you guys do in the
background is you actually
cache all those values in
order to basically make the
UI as fast as it was.
Can you just verify that?
I thought that was true.
I just wanted to make sure.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Yes.
We provide the functionality to
import key values and geo
data from the DFP ad server, and
so we can store it in our
Salesforce app.
And the user can access every
data they have in the ad
server, in the DFP server.
PAUL RASHIDI: Perfect.
So there's no double-syncing
going on, or
anything like that.
You just pull all the data,
and make it immediately
available on Salesforce.
NADJA STREISS: Yes, we have.
Basically it.
PAUL RASHIDI: Vincent,
have you got
your audio issue resolved?
Maybe not.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Oh,
I don't think so.
NADJA STREISS: Doesn't
look like.
PAUL RASHIDI: All right.
So I'll just ask a quick--
one of his quick questions.
So I think he had--
on chat he's telling me, what
was one of the most difficult
API services to work
with, and why?
FREDERIK LADEWIG: I don't
think that we had much
difficulties with
any ad service.
In the beginning, we had
some problems with
the line item service.
But right now, all problems
were changed.
We had some problems that not
all features were supported.
But right now, I think every
service is active.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: --usable.
PAUL RASHIDI: I always like to
ask to see how we can improve.
So I think one of his other
questions was, are there any
features you'd like to
see us add to the
DFP API in the future?
FREDERIK LADEWIG: I personally
would like to see a feature
where you can ask over the API
what features are available in
what network.
For example, I think you have
some features that you have to
activate for every network.
And the networks are
somehow different.
Sometimes we have problems
with different network
configurations.
So I think we would like is a
better functionality to ask a
network what feature
is activated.
PAUL RASHIDI: That
sounds fair.
That way, you could essentially
do an initial
check when you connect to a
network to make sure that you
have all the permissions you
need, and things like that.
Correct.
OK, great.
I don't think we got
Vincent back.
So I don't have any
more questions.
Oh, we can--
Great.
All right.
Well, thank you very much for
joining us, ADvendio, Nadja,
Reno, and Frederik.
So I guess we'll go ahead
and sign off.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Yes.
PAUL RASHIDI: Thanks
a lot, guys.
NADJA STREISS: Have
a good day.
FREDERIK LADEWIG: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]